Michael remembers exactly what went
through his head the day he was
diagnosed with HIV it was in January
last year he knew his life had changed
forever you know not only is it my first
thought was would I still be able to
find work oh no I'm positive I had this
idea of jumping off a bridge
oh my god I need to die oh my god I need
to die
Michael is 21 and one of some 35,000
people known to live with HIV in the
Philippines he fears being stigmatized
so he asked us not to show his face as a
teenager he sold sex to other men often
without using a condom knowledge about
HIV and how the virus is transmitted is
still patchy among many Filipinos the
ignorance leads not only to higher
infection rates but also feeds fear and
rejection even in Michael's family so
every day when I got home every day when
I came home my mom would separate my
plates and cutlery from those of the
others she said we needed to keep them
apart I always had the feeling they
found me repulsive after years of
playing down how severely HIV AIDS is
impacting young men like Michael the
government now seems to be changing
course it's at high schools like this
one here in Manila where the Philippine
government wants to start tackling the
HIV epidemic for example by offering
better sex education to teenagers a
proposal that has sparked fierce
criticism from parents conservative
lawmakers but also the church in this
deeply Catholic country critics have
already forced officials to scrap the
idea of making condoms available at
schools they're afraid it would
encourage children to become promiscuous
conservatives say sex education doesn't
belong in the classroom the first
teachers of the children are their
parents
for heaven's sake the parents are not
only supposed to give them food board
and lodging but also to teach them value
system behavioral patterns etc etc to be
good members of society and among other
things is this matter of sexual
education it belongs primarily by right
and by duty to the parish themselves to
do this it's not an approach Michael
things can work neither parents nor
teenagers feel comfortable talking about
sex he himself has become a peer
educator he wants to spare other young
people his fate megumi say everything
starts with knowing once people have
adequate knowledge the right information
about hiv/aids teen pregnancy condoms
and other things you'll be armed your
knowledge will be your shield and your
sword that way you can protect yourself
and at the same time protect other young
people especially those who are close to
you Michael knows he's facing an uphill
battle but for him every HIV case he can
prevent by sharing what he's had to
learn the hard way is a victory